We have a great voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
And I have a new top caller to play for you
today.
This is a caller who I don't really understand
their message.
There's an indescribable jenness, say, quod
to this voicemail.
There seems to be xylophone music playing
in the background.
It's an incredibly well produced voicemail.
I don't know what to make of it, but I absolutely
love it.
Take a listen to this.
Thank you.
Especially with all the representatives that
are in any way.
It's great to hear your voice.
And I'm so proud of you.
And all of that happened to me.
A good.
Yeah.
You brought me to the success of recognizing
television.
And I'm proud of this presentation that you
represent.
And thank heavens for your father and mother
for bringing no substantial intelligence.
Gentlemen, on television.
I'm the wrong gentleman.
I made a mistake before when I was somebody.
Presentations on how great you are.
Yeah, I was thinking about you would be a
candidate for president.
Well, two four six five zero.
Oh, well, OK.
We do want to put out the we don't want to
put out their phone number.
Of course, I cannot be president under the
current law because I was born in another
country.
I immigrated to the United States from Argentina
so I can never be president unless the law
is changed.
But I really appreciate that the xylophone
in the background is a beautiful, beautiful
touch.
I don't know if that's digitally added or
what's going on.
But thank you.
I don't know that I have been called a gentleman
in any voicemail before.
Usually I'm called other things and it's not
quite so good.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Georgia Governor Brian Kemp is banning mask
mandates, banning mask mandates.
This will lead to unnecessary deaths.
OK, period.
People will die who didn't have to because
Brian Kemp, governor of Georgia, is saying
cities cannot require masks to be worn.
A California city has moved to replace police
with unarmed civilians for certain types of
traffic stops.
It's a very interesting proposal, which we
will discuss.
And lastly, we now are getting more and more
data about the rehiring that is going on in
some sectors of the economy.
And what we are seeing small businesses do
is, yes, rehire staff, but often at lower
pay and often at fewer hours, according to
a new survey publicized by CNBC.
So we're going to talk about that on the bonus
show as well.
Remember, you can get instant access to the
bonus show by becoming a member at join Pacman
dot com, if you would like a discount off
of your membership.
Give a try to the coupon code.
July surprise.
All one word, all lowercase July surprise.
I think we'll give you a nice little surprise
when you use that coupon code on a new membership
at join Pacman dot com.
And remember, as always, you can get the daily
audio podcast for free on whatever your favorite
podcasting app is.
If you are going back to work and commuting
and you want something to listen to.
If you're biking around a very safe corona
virus activity, I'm listening to podcasts
when I bike around Boston, of course, wearing
a mask and the full thing.
Consider The David Pakman Show audio podcast,
Spotify, iTunes, et cetera, et cetera.
I'll see you on the boat show.